Let's now take a little bit of a look at what's
going on with Corona virus.
We've got four more days of data.
The Corona virus pandemic is kind of settling
now into trends that are more about policy
than early hot spots.
And it is becoming very clear that it is overwhelmingly
red states where the case growth is explosive.
Now, in the United States, in general, red
states have worse education.
They have worse health care.
They have lower incomes, they have more poverty.
And these are trends that we've seen in the
United States for a long time now.
Early on in Corona virus, there were many
right wingers who were almost delighting from
seeing hot spots in large democratic cities,
often within Democratic states.
We are now more than three months in.
We're starting to see corona virus spread
correlate more with policy than simply where
did it go first?
And with some small exceptions, this is increasingly
a red state problem.
Take a look at this map where you will see
a county by county growth level where either
the trends are going in the right direction
or in the wrong direction.
And this is a much more precise way than simply
looking at states or the country.
If you're what I'll describe to you what we're
looking at.
But if you're watching, you will notice there
are green and yellow colored counties.
Those are doing well.
That means they are either fully or almost
under control with corona virus.
You then have orange and red counties, which
are not good.
OK.
And as you can see, huge swaths of the country,
including the northeast, most of the West
Coast other than California, which continues
to be a problem, much of the bluer states
in between are going in the right direction.
And yet at a country level, we have crazy
numbers of new corona virus cases.
How can this be?
Well, it's because of the really disastrous
red state counties.
Almost all of Arizona is going the wrong way.
Large parts of Texas, Louisiana, Alabama,
Arkansas, Oklahoma, Georgia, both Carolinas,
Florida.
And if you look at day to day case numbers,
the places that are now regularly having the
new single day case records are still California.
We've talked about California, but then it's
places like Florida, Texas, Arizona, again,
the Carolinas, Georgia, couple of the early
hot spots, New York and Illinois, but then
Tennessee, Virginia, Ohio.
So do we have a unifying theory about what
is going on here?
We actually do.
And I'm going to tell you what it is so that
when these right wingers trot out the bogus
talking points, you don't fall from them to
fall for them.
Some of the talking points we're hearing from
the right are things like this is a Democratic
city problem which spread.
No thanks to them into red states.
It's the fault of the Democrats.
We've heard red states have more cases because
they have more testing.
We've heard this was allowed in from China
because of stupid liberal blue state governors.
And now we all have a problem thanks to them.
We've heard the numbers are simply fake.
We've heard southern states are a problem
because Mexicans are bringing the virus across
the border.
All of this is wrong.
Trump brags that now no one is coming over
the U.S. Mexico border.
Trump has said the border is stronger than
ever other than states lying about how low
they claim cases to be.
The huge case numbers are not because there
is more testing going on.
There really are more cases.
This is all not true.
And here is the unifying theory to understand.
Early on, late 2019, early 2020.
Before we knew what was going on, before we
understood the disease and how it spread,
the disease was seeded planted in urban areas
with high direct traffic to the early hotspot.
So here in Boston, we have tons of flights
to Europe and to China and other parts of
Asia.
Nonstop flights here to Shanghai, Hong Kong,
Japan, multiple city, you know, Beijing, etc..
So it was seeded here in Boston.
New York has two major airports that connect
directly to China.
In Europe, JFK and Newark, Pennsylvania, was
an early hotspot.
American Airlines is a huge hub in Philadelphia.
Huge flight hub back and forth to Europe and
even some flights to Asia.
Chicago is a big hub for American Airlines
and United.
Many international airlines also have non
stops to Chicago.
You've got Los Angeles and San Francisco airport.
So for two to three months, Corona virus was
being seeded before we knew what was going
on.
And that's why those were the early.
Hotspots.
When we learned about what was going on and
started stay at home orders, those places
already had a huge amount of disease before
we even had testing capacity.
It was spreading for weeks.
And you had a large base population which
contributed to huge spread in these places.
We had it here in Boston, New York, Chicago,
etc.
So early this spread was heavily related to
where are people flying in and out of and
giving it to other people.
Now, over time, some states adopted serious
policies for mitigation and some states did
not.
And over time, the numbers became less about
flights and air travel, which have all but
stopped, but more about policy.
And once you let the policy differences play
out for a few months, you see these dramatic
reductions in places that were early hot spots.
Massachusetts, New York, Illinois, Pennsylvania,
which are crushing the disease right now.
Fortunately, I'm really thrilled, by the way.
But what's going on here in Massachusetts?
Things slowly reopening, safely reopening,
which is good to see.
And you see the explosion in the places that
didn't have strict guidelines or they were
simply ignored.
That's what's going on in California.
By the way.
California has strict guidelines, but from
all of the people I know living there, a lot
of people are just ignoring them.
That explains California.
It also explains Arizona, Florida, Carolinas,
Georgia, Oklahoma, Arkansas, Alabama, Louisiana
as the new growing hot spots.
So policy clearly does matter.
And at the rate things are going, if you don't
reverse what's going on right now in 15 days,
you are going to have a large portion of the
U.S. south that is going to be the world hot
spot.
There are states already Arizona's growth
rate for cases exceeds some of the worst countries
right now.
Arizona on its own.
And meanwhile, Donald Trump held a rally in
such a hot spot.
Oklahoma, whose case rate is going up dramatically.
So that is the lay of the land right now.
We'll have some more detail about this tomorrow.
I am now on Cameo.
You can book me to troll your friends.
I got booked for a bunch of Father's Day messages
this week.
Cameo dot com, slash David Pakman or just
search my name on the cameo app.
Tomorrow I'm going to have a really funny
video I did for somebody on Cameo, but we'll
take a quick break and be back after this.